D
NOTHING ELSE.
THAT CAN'T DO ANYTHING TO HELP
THIS COUNTRY.
>> I DON'T ENVY YOU HOSTING THIS
BLOCK.
HERE IS WHY.
BECAUSE NONE OF MAKES ANY SENSE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY AGREES
WITH THIS AND I WILL CHALLENGE
YOU, I THINK HE IS THE ONLY
PERSON THERE -- HE/SHE IS THE
ONLY PERSON THAT CAN BE
BLACKMAILED.
OKAY YOU CAN'T BLACKMAILED ME.
GOT HIM.
THERE'S NO WAY THEY CHECKED THIS
GUY OUT.
THEY DID CHECK IT OUT AND THEY
SHOULD PURSUE THIS.
LISTEN, AND ALL THE STUFF IS
POSTED.
YOU ARE THE GUY WHO SHOULD
HANDLE NUCLEAR WASTE.
HE WILL BE PERFECT.
ONLY 35.
NOT MUCH OF AN ENERGY BACKGROUND
AND INTEND TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIMES IN DIFFERENT OUTFITS.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF THAT.
>> Jeanine: THIS GUY TAKES
SUITCASES.
>> HE GETS THE JOB OF THE
LIFETIME AND HE REWARDS HIMSELF
AND THEY PUT HIM THERE BY
STEALING LUGGAGE AND GETTING
ARRESTED AND IMPRISONED
EVERYONE.
I DON'T THINK, I THINK 99% OF
THE PEOPLE WATCHING US WHO HAVE
A TELEVISION THINK THIS IS CRAZY
TOWN AND OBJECTIVITY
INDIVIDUALISM IS NOT WHITE
SUPREMACY.
>> ONE MORE POINT.
HE IS A POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
SO HE IS NOT PROTECTED BY THE
CAREER CIVIL SERVICE RULES.
YOU SERVE WITH THE PLEASURE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
YOU COULD BE FIRED FOR SAYING
HELLO TO THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WRONG WAY.
THE FACT THAT THEY DID NOT
IMMEDIATELY FIRE HIM IS AN
ISSUE.
>> Jeanine: THE QUESTION,
JESSICA, IS IF IT IS ALL ABOUT
WOKENESS OVERCONFIDENCE, PUTTING
AMERICA IN A TOUGH SITUATION AND
IF SENATORS ARE READY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND ASKING
FOR ANSWERS ON HOW THEY LET
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THEY ARE NOT
GETTING ANSWERS, AFTER A THIRD
LETTER, I MEAN, CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION JUST HIDE AND
SAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO TELL
YOU?
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
>> Jessica: I TOTALLY AGREE.
I SAW THAT THE SENATOR WAS
LEADING THE CHARGE ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
HAS NOT MENTIONED ONCE THAT THIS
IS A GENDER FLUID PERSON OR
TALKED ABOUT PRONOUNS.
THIS IS ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY
AND THAT IS WHERE THIS
CONVERSATION SHOULD BE AND THAT
IS WHERE IT SHOULD STAY.
IN TERMS OF JUST MAKING WOKENESS
APPOINTMENTS, I WOULD PUSH BACK,
YOU KNOW, HARDLY AGAINST THE
IDEA THAT KAMALA HARRIS AND THIS
PERSON ARE COMPARABLE IN ANY WAY
IN TERMS OF GETTING THEIR
POSITION AND I KNOW HOW YOU FEEL
ABOUT HER.
BUT THAT WOMAN IS QUALIFIED FOR
THIS JOB AND EVERYBODY WHO WINS
AN ELECTION OR TRANSFER OF
ELECTION IS PERFECT FOR A
POSITION, HAS CERTAIN ATTRIBUTES
AND IT DOES MATTER THAT SHE IS A
BLACK WOMAN, THE SAME WAY IT
MATTERED THAT MIKE PENCE WAS A
WHITE EVANGELICAL.
>> DO YOU THINK THE COLOR OF HIS
SKIN, MIKE PENCE THE JOB?
>> NO, HIS RELIGION BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP 50 TIME -- AFTER
THE YOU KNOW WHAT TYPE NEEDED
SOME HELP WITH PEOPLE OF FAITH.
RIGHT?
WHO WERE NOT INTERESTED IN
VOTING FOR SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
STOP DIMINISHING KAMALA HARRIS.
>> YOU CAN SAY SHE IS GREAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO STOP.
>> OKAY.
SO DEL MAR AND BARACK OBAMA HAVE
BEEN TALKED ABOUT IS MAKING
PEOPLE FEEL BAD ABOUT WHEN THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY ABOUT
PRONOUNS OR JUST DON'T MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL BAD ABOUT THINGS
THAT ALSO ON THE FLIPSIDE OF
THAT, IT DOES NOT TAKE THAT MUCH
TO FIND OUT HOW SOMEBODY WANTS
TO BE ADDRESSED AND IF YOU DO
KNOW THAT DO NOT INTENTIONALLY
MAKE FUN OF THEM OR CHANGE THE
WAY THAT THEY LIVE FOR YOUR OWN
COMFORTABILITY.
LIKE YOU SAID, I'M NERVOUS TO
SAY X, Y, AND Z.
>> I AM NERVOUS.
>> THAT IS FINE.
I SAID NO ONE SHOULD BE MADE TO
FEEL BAD IF THEY ARE MAKING A
GENUINE EFFORT TO TREAT PEOPLE
WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY.
>> HOW ABOUT THIS?
I IDENTIFY AS A DOCTOR.
REFERRED TO ME AS DR. WATERS.
>> PhD OR MEDICAL, I'M PhD.
I'M NOT GOING TO --
[OVERLAPPING SPEAKER